[Music]
[Applause]
Magic Johnson said to join us and of
course the Hall of Famer greatest point
guard of all time he uh is working with
GSK they recently launched sideline
RSV and more to tell us tell us more
about that Magic Johnson how did you get
involved in this product sideline RSV
well you know uh the great thing is GSK
approached me since I'm 60 and older now
I'm 64 years old and RSV is is really
you have to pay attention 60 and older
and
177 000 people get hospitalized uh with
RSV and then out of that 14
000 uh dies so it's a really important
message we want everybody 60 and older
to make sure they talk to their doctor
health care provider or pharmacist and
we have to remember if you have chronic
heart or lung disease you should really
consult your doctor about RSV because
it's it's it's so so important yeah
respiratory virus that magic's talking
about how's your health
my health is good still working out five
days a week
um and what's really good then is that
uh they have vaccination now for RSV and
so I'm gonna get vaccinated uh I did it
for covert and everything else and now
I'm gonna do it for RSV what about a
senior NBA All-Star Game
[Laughter]
it would get hurt
now if it was a horse game okay or
something like that okay I could see
that but anything other than that no no
no no no no senior game how would the
NBA be without a three-point shot
um
it would still be good but I think that
uh
the NBA three-point shot has really
revolutionized the game you think about
what Steph Curry is doing and all the
other shooters that we have in the game
today and then think about all the
European players most of them shoot
threes and
um it's open up the lane two is open up
the game the game is different when I
played Dan remember it was inside out
now it's outside in with all the
three-point shooting but it's it's great
for the game
how would you well you would have
practiced more as a three-point shooter
if if you were if it was welcome back
then it didn't feel like it was the
weapon you almost did it as a
desperation shot
yeah it was it was different right
because again
um if it was really a big tool back then
we would have used it more on my on our
team that we had you know probably Byron
Scott uh Michael Cooper were our
three-point Shooters but
um we had Kareem myself James uh worthy
inside so uh the ball went inside and
that's how we were able to win but again
uh it's a weapon today
um to me a lot of guys who can't shoot
still shoot three pointers I think a lot
of times uh I would like to see just the
guys who could really shoot it shoot the
three but uh that's the way it is to in
today's NBA but would Kareem have been
shooting three-pointers if he was
brought up in today's game
um probably because uh one thing about
Kareem he was so dominant Dan that uh he
was just listen I'm glad that he didn't
I saw the hook shot he could shoot uh
Bank shots he can make his free throws I
mean he was just a dominant player so
I'm glad he came uh in terms of when he
was playing basketball when I was
playing because I would have never saw
those dominant performance since that
Kareem uh displayed and he was MVP he
was the best player when I came in
remember Kareem was the best player in
the league for uh what a six seven year
stretch there yeah so he was dominant
talking to Magic Johnson yeah I I feel
Kareem is underrated like it feels like
I don't know it's just weird I don't
know if you sense that like we we blew
by Kareem then it was Mike and you and
Larry and now you got Steph and you know
Shaq and knows LeBron it just felt like
Kareem was from a different generation
well because because uh social media and
all that now we don't talk about him as
much but we have to remember that he was
the most Unstoppable Force
uh certainly when I played
um in the game and he was Unstoppable on
both ends I mean not only did he
dominate with the hook shot on offense
but also he was blocking a lot of shots
and changing a lot of shots and he was
able to run the floor Kareem was so
agile and uh and he could pass the
basketball too so uh you're right he's
gonna always be overlooked because of
probably the age and uh when he played
but I tell you what if you go Google or
YouTube or whatever you have to do
you will see a dominant big man and
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
uh uh if I said you could only watch one
Dodgers Lakers commanders oh my goodness
[Laughter]
well the commanders are still still new
uh and you know I love my Dodgers I love
baseball
but I'm a Laker guy I mean I play
basketball so if I I'm ever put in a
position I can only choose one imma
choose watching basketball my Lakers and
then one a is the Lakers one B would be
my Dodgers and then one C because I just
got the Commanders
but uh they'll be coming on strong here
uh as soon as we you know have a chance
to build them okay what kind of football
fan were did you play football at all in
high school yeah I played football uh
Pop Warner up until high school and then
my coach told me no way I could be three
weeks late uh because football season
ran into basketball and he didn't want
me to be three weeks late I'll probably
be not in proper basketball shape so I
quit once I got to high school okay what
position did you play at six nine both
ends offensive end and uh defensive end
were you good
I was just okay
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna
go home because that's okay
and uh but I had a lot of fun playing
with my friends but basketball has
always been my game but I wonder I I
remember asking football players about
how would Shaq be as a football player
and they were like right it wouldn't be
we wouldn't be afraid of Shaq or Lebron
like you know a big man in football is
you know Aaron Donald six foot 275
pounds in in basketball a big guy is Yao
Ming or Shaq or Mark Eaton
well you know I think that
it's hard to
say a football player could go into the
NBA and it's hard for an NBA player to
go into football I think it's it's so
difficult there are two different games
um but
you know both are special athletes a
football players a special athlete uh
NBA guy is a special athlete and that's
why also we admire each other and uh
um I'd like to have seen Iverson play
football
now if anybody probably could pull it
off it'd probably been
you know AI I think he uh he played
football he played quarterback and
um he like you said he's a special
athlete and uh and maybe Deion Sanders
could have went though football to
basketball you know you you see certain
athletes that probably could pull it off
uh but they were dominant in their sport
they probably wouldn't have been
dominant in the other sport right
obviously wouldn't have been dominated
in football like he was in basketball
for uh finding out more about sideline
RSV you can go to sideline rsv.com great
to talk to you magic thank you uh good
luck with your Lakers and your Dodgers
and you're going to need luck with your
commanders at least uh this season yeah
we're building them I'm happy that I'm
an owner and we're building it Dan thank
you magic all right take care that's
Magic Johnson he's part of the ownership
of the Commanders